Do you feel any sense of,
and I've heard you talk about Instagram filters,
so there's kind of that beat on the street with it,
but growing up in the world,
I mean, you know, there were painstaking measures you took
to fall into this cookie-cutter silhouette.
It's like we put ourselves,
we elected to be in a business
that has some really screwed up values at times,
but is there a sense of relief in going,
"Yeah, I'm not perfect.
I don't fit the mold and screw it.
I'm so sick of living trying to pretend I do,
it actually was killing me.
So in order to save myself, I'm gonna tell you the truth.
And if you can like me for that, then great."
Yes, you nailed it.
That's the perfect soundbite for my documentary,
and why I put it out was exactly that,
was like, I was trying something that didn't work for me,
now I'm doing something that is working for me.
Instead of feeling judged by everyone,
I'm just gonna say,
"Look, your opinion about me doesn't matter to me.
I'm doing what I need to do for myself and my wellness,
my well-being."
Like I'm putting myself first in front of my career,
and that's something I never did before
because I was so preoccupied
trying to be the sexy feminine pop star
that I just ignored who I am.
I don't know,
I cut my hair because I just wanted to free myself
of all of the gender and sexuality norms
that were placed on me as a Christian in the South.
And when I cut my hair I felt so liberated,
because I wasn't subscribing to an ideal
or a belief placed upon me to be something that I'm not.
And now that I'm owning who I am,
I feel the happiest I've ever felt.
And that's because I'm being honest, you know,
secrets keep you sick.
I've heard that a million times and I fully believe it.
Now there's nothing,
there's no secrets for the world to find out,
I just put it out there,
and I'm like, hey, this is it, this is me.
If you don't like it, fine.
But if this provokes a conversation,
and raises awareness,
takes away the stigma about the topics I'm talking about,
then that's what I want
is to just open people's perspectives
and to change the conversation around recovery too.
When you talk about secrets,
something that really touched me personally
in the documentary was at a certain point in my life
when I did start kind of getting overconfident
about where I was at with my drinking and things,
I did start to hide things from people,
and I noticed you were really good
at hiding things from people.
Like they would say, they don't know, like they didn't know.
And you were like, "But you were even there that night,
you were there that day, how did you not know?"
And I was curious, thank God, I have some friends who,
although I thought I was good at hiding things,
they are extremely tough love oriented people.
And in a lot of the ways
they were good karmatic compensation
for all the Hollywood people
who did not put you in your place, indulged,
gave you access, and never would say a thing
because God forbid they got cut out of your orbit.
Some of my best, best friends are people,
you know, they're not in the industry.
Yeah.
And it's really fun because they are so down to earth,
so chill that I find myself gravitating towards them
over other industry people.
Because my friend,
I came home one day, I'd done like interview...
I'm living with one of my best friends and-
So fun!
Yeah, totally!
Well, I was just in a...
I was engaged to a dude and almost did that.
And I was like, hmm, that's not the life for me,
I wanna have fun and I wanna live with my friends.
Let's normalize that, you know.
And so anyways, I just-
Demi, if I didn't have two children,
I would actually ask you if you wanted to be roommates
because-
Wow, I'd say yes in a heartbeat.
But some of my happiest moments in my life
are without question,
and I moved out on my own when I was 14,
so I banked a lot of years with roommates, my girlfriends,
it is some of the happiest times of my life
is living with my friends.
Yeah, totally.
I wouldn't be surprised or I invite all of them
to go back to it at some point.
Like, should we not just all end up
in a happy commune anyway?
Yeah, definitely!
I came home one day after doing interviews
and photo shoots and whatnot,
and she was like, "Hey, Demi.
So you've been doing rockstar (beep) all day,
you wanna do some normal (beep)?"
And I was like, "Yes, that's what I want."
And then we put on "Grey's Anatomy" and "The Walking Dead".
And it was over from there.
That is good.
Absolutely.
(upbeat music)